it's it's not easy to be great it's very
challenging the commitment the
consistency over time and that's one of
the things Kobe studies just like it's
simple math I just put in double the
hours as everyone else when I was a
teenager it's the first year he started
playing basketball at summer camp
he didn't score one point in this whole
like summer and this tournament that he
played in and then he started doing
double the hours in the next year he was
like the highest scorer he was like it
was simple math I wasn't more talented I
simply put in more hours that's a pretty
solid Segway for about 30 reasons to get
to a little bit of your chat with Kobe
Bryant because I think it in Kapil
encapsulates so much what you're talking
about so I watched it again this morning
and we talked about it when I was on
your show and I hadn't seen the
interviews of you and Kobe and what I
said to you and that interview was that
this was just you know a few weeks after
every night is that it felt like it was
like a rip in the universe because it's
hard to fathom
putting aside the tragedy of all the
other people in his daughter yeah yeah
but those aren't public people that we
know but of course it's as as equal a
tragedy obviously but there was
something about Kobe that it was like I
told you I was watching sports you know
the the spectrum Lakers Channel the day
before and I saw him and he was just
being interviewed he's in a suit and
he's got the beer he looks really sharp
and I was like man that guy's just
living his best life that was literally
the day before ha and it feels like a
rip in the universe when someone who's
doing all of the things that you just
described who has reached the pinnacle
of their sport but then flourished after
and started this Basketball Academy and
a good jillion other things then
disappears from the earth so can you
just talk a little bit about what it was
like to sit down with Kobe and what he
taught you and did he have all of those
pieces cuz cuz literally just everything
that you just laid out right there
that's what he was talking about in the
interview and you could see it was real
there was no BS mind yeah it was a
powerful experience the whole the whole
set of
it was powerful we booked the interview
the day before so I didn't have much
time to prep which was probably a good
thing for me because I didn't have like
two weeks to think about I've got Kobe
it's like literally booked it at 6:00
p.m. I think the night before and then I
was there at 6:00 a.m. the next morning
in his office in the OC and I remember
the most powerful thing he taught me was
not what he said but his example and
what I mean by that is when we got to
his office I think was probably around
6:15 6:30 the interviewers were at 8
o'clock and I knew I was the publicist
was like you got 20 minutes I think she
originally said you got 15 minutes but I
was like please give me 20 right ok when
I asked two questions
yeah we get there and the assistant
opens the door for us and there's a big
office base in the Orange County and she
says here's where we normally film but
in my mind I was like that doesn't
really look that good can I look around
the office and see if there's another
spot we can set up our cameras so we
walk through the office and we'd go down
kind of this long hall with corporate
rooms on each side of the hallway with
glass windows so you can see inside the
conference rooms and then it walks down
into another big open space of more
office chairs and things like that we
walked down I see the other room I'm
like I don't like anything here let's go
back to the original space so we walked
back through the the glass hallway and
the last window on the left I see it the
lights are off in the back of the room
probably 20 30 feet back I see a shadow
of a man like this looking up just
looking up at the ceiling and no
computer schemers on there was no phone
in his hand and I looked real quick
double take and I see it's Kobe sitting
there like this just looking up this is
6:15 in the morning and I'm thinking our
neighbors not till 8:00 and I'm thinking
myself I asked the assistant I go is
that Kobe yeah and I go what's he doing
here so early like this is his company
this is his space why is he here she
goes he's been here for almost an hour
and he was at the gym with his daughter
I'm gonna passed away at 4:00 a.m.
working out with her and he comes here
he's always the first one here and he's
always the most prepared and I'll go
just that moment alone of seeing Kobe as
a shadow
looking up and I can only imagine he was
visualizing his dream he was going over
you know his game film for the day he
was planning what he was gonna be
talking about there was an interview
with me afterwards with a little Wayne
who was there so they were setting up
another part it was kind of surreal just
morning little Wayne and all his
bodyguards and this whole Cardew crew is
there I'm there with one person setting
you up our three cameras and like hey
you know and I'm just like this is
surreal and about an hour about 15
minutes before our interview so for
another hour hour and a half the lights
are off in this room and now people
started to come in around 8:30 in the
office and so there's some come oh
there's some activity happening and I'm
sitting there in the chair just kind of
waiting just trying to like be ready I
don't know if he's he gonna come out
early is he coming out on time I don't
know what's happening he ends up coming
out probably two minutes before 8
o'clock the start time and the the
publicist gave me a bunch of papers of
everything not to ask him a list of
things you cannot talk about from his
past or his parents to all these things
like don't mention this don't mention
this I mean a list and I've never had
this before mm-hmm and so I know to
myself I've got two minutes to connect
with arguably the greatest of all time
who's just won an Oscar as well by the
way and two minutes of Connect before
our 20 minute interview right what am I
gonna say and hopefully he doesn't you
know when you meet people that are
really need famous and you're inspired
by then you meet them in like gosh I'm
really let down by them they say never
meet you here right yeah and this guy
was a complete opposite he was right
away came up to me gave me a big
handshake I'm just like hey thank you so
much for being here really means a lot
to me we're trying to get the message
out about our podcast like thank you for
taking the time looked me in the eyes
first thing I said to him was like I
just want to say thank you I work with
friends with a lot of Olympians and all
of them say that during the last couple
Olympics you were the most giving
athlete that you would show up to to
other sporting events that you would
take photos with everyone in the you
know in the village and during lunches
that you were just so Connie giving so
as a as a USA handball player I want
you for how you show up during this
times and right away he goes
you play handball I go yeah I love
handball and he goes I love handball
playing it in Italy growing up that's
all I did is a fun activity and I go
amazing yeah it's such a great sport I
wish we had it here the USA more and
then I mentioned a couple of people we
had in common and he's like man those
guys are my brothers like I love that
I'm glad we have some good connections
and I said one more thing I said you
know your your team has told me what not
to share I will not talk about is there
anything else off-limits that I
shouldn't talk about and he said rip
that up ask me anything you want take as
long as you want so I was only supposed
to have 20 minutes we have to thing we
went 40 or 45 and I tried to be
respectful because the publicist kept
saying I could wrap it up in the
background and I was like okay that
would be respectful but even the last
few questions he answered was talking
about like his whole mission was to tell
great stories and him talking about love
and family for me it was really
inspiring not only the words he says but
his example he isn't just saying work
hard and I'll work everyone he's
actually showed me as an example I
didn't know if he was gonna if he was
gonna see me seeing him that morning
like he didn't think I was gonna walk
past his office cuz I wasn't supposed to
right but he was there and just that
example of I don't get there to my place
for 30 minutes before my interviews
right you I guess I mean you come in
when you're ready but it's like just
that example of hard work as shows why
he was so great and that was inspiring
to me isn't it interesting that you know
they say the same thing about Michael
Jordan he outworked everybody he
practiced the hardest like you'd think
that every athlete would be like oh
that's the obvious ready to do it or
forget athletes that all of us in our
lives would be like oh you want to be
the best at what you do and you got to
work the hardest you got to show up
first and you got to leave last and blah
blah blah and yet 99.999% of us don't do
it you know you look at the guys that
you admire most and they're the ones
doing it it's a big sacrifice it's a lot
of time or a lot of energy and you you
have to give up so much to go all in on
one thing
so I know why it's hard to do I mean
it's like he was up before he am working
out with his daughter and then he was at
the office at 5:30 or whatever it was
her 6:00 or whatever it was and it's
like it's a sacrifice we'd much rather
be comfortable and sleep more and watch
Netflix more I like watching Netflix
it's it's not easy to be great it's very
challenging the commitment the
consistency over time and that's one of
the things Kobe studies just like it's
simple math I just put in double the
hours as everyone else when I was a
teenager it's the first year he started
playing basketball at summer camp
he didn't score one point in this whole
like summer and this tournament that he
played in and then he started doing
double the hours in the next year he was
like the highest scorer he was like it
was simple math I wasn't more talented I
simply put in more hours it's a good
transition to something else that he
said that I think is interesting where
he talked you were asking him about when
he was sort of hitting his stride and he
talks about this moment where Shaq is
injured for like eight games and he sort
I think forty over forty and eight
straight games or something like that
and then Phil Jackson calls him into the
office when Shaq comes back and
basically is like now you got to tone it
down because now Shaq is back and the
East plays different so when we get to
the finals we have to do this
differently and he you know you'd think
that he would just be like no we're
winning like crazy
I'm dominator than Shaq we don't even
need Shaq you know they had their own
problems later but but he basically was
like yeah so I listened to the to the
mentor that's what I wanted to get to
because you talked a lot about
mentorship he listened to the mentor in
this case Phil Jackson who had already
done this with Jordan and he dialed it
back and then of course they end up
exactly if you'd like to be inspired
motivated and educated by some of the
most successful people around the world
check out the school of greatness full
episode playlist right over here and if
you'd like to see Louis houses interview
with me click right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell